ma mère m'a placé en bout de table entre
les jumeaux de mon frère depuis
j'élabore une stratégie et bientôt je
dirais une phrase qui aura un gros
impact sur moi et sur quelques autres
personnes et côté j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un sérieux quoi il faut que tu
nous le présente bientôt amelia noël
c'est donc comme ça que je me suis mise
dans la merde
tt inventé un ex sérieux ouais alors il
faut que tu te trouves un mec quoi en 24
jours ouais je te donnerai un coup de
main tu vas trouver les voies d'emmener
à l'appeler leur match on va pimenter sa
vie amoureuse
regardez souris
[Musique]
alors ça coïncidence johannes hahn est
il écrit ici que tu as 29 ans tu me
rappelle ma maman
je sais même plus combien de rang car
j'ai eu et tous ces types y font comme
si j'étais pas là ils écoutent rien du
tout oui tu devrais pas juger les hommes
s'est rapidement il faut que tu vives
comme toi tu l'entends ne laisse pas les
oat 10 pts et comment vivre ta vie
il sera bientôt là prenez votre mal en
patience
[Musique]
bon qu'on soit clair tous les deux je
suis pas plus haut hier j'ai couché avec
un dragon